hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i've made quite a
lot of money in property over the last
decade and now i spend a lot of my time
answering people's questions about
property investment on youtube
so thank you so much for coming to my
channel please do smash the like button
if you enjoy my content
and also don't forget to subscribe and
turn the notification bell on so you
don't miss future videos
now i'm going to be taking some
questions from last week's video however
i want to answer
your sticky tricky property investment
question so if you've got any questions
around finance business tax mortgages
buy to let property hmo service
accommodation lease option agreements
rent to rent deal packaging anything at
all
comment below and next week i will
answer your questions so let's see we
had from last week
um rhys nibs says one of your winners
wednesday students
said they're refinancing a house bought
with cash
but how can you refinance a house which
doesn't have a mortgage on it
so very simply you can
refinance a house that doesn't have a
mortgage on it
by getting a mortgage on it so that
would be called refinancing it
um yeah i don't really know what else to
say
let's see what else we've got chase mast
on
where do you get the money to refurbish
a home if buying with no
money down okay so if you buy a house
no money down i.e you take control of it
or you buy it with a bank loan or you do
it as a joint venture
your question is how do you then
refurbish the house
my answer would be the same way that you
finance the house in the first place
if you if you finance the house in the
first place by using an investor's money
then use that same investor's money to
do the refurb
if you did it with a bank loan then then
get a bank loan
or buy a house that doesn't need a
refurb or if you're doing
buy refurbished refinance and you're
buying a house and refurbing it to
refinance it
there was a lot of bridging companies
that would give you 100 development
finance
and then you can then just refinance it
on a buy to let mortgage so i guess it's
quite a
big question it would depend on the
specifics
if you have a specific property in mind
tell me more about it and i'll do my
best to answer next week
adil says i tried to message a landlord
on spare room to ask if they wanted
guaranteed rent via a rent to rent deal
and i was banned from spare room okay
because i went against their policies so
i wouldn't recommend going through spare
room
um yeah adele i wouldn't say don't go
through sparrow
maybe a couple tips number one i
probably even when i saw what you said
when you said
i asked them if they wanted a guaranteed
rent via rent to rent it sounds a little
bit
uh weird landlords might report you
i would be more inclined to say i'm a
management company
you know if you'd be interested in
receiving a guaranteed rent or even
selling i'd love to have a chat with you
that might be a little bit of a better
approach but you are correct
if you send lots of messages to
landlords on spare room
sparing will pick it up because they
will sense that it is not genuine
and they might block your account so
probably the best thing to do is on
spare room
see what the person's actual email is
direct or
even their phone number direct and then
message them direct
rather than using the sparing platform
to send lots of messages
but good luck and i'm glad that you take
your massive action
and i hope to see you smash it on rent
tourette's respect
jose says hi samuel if i buy a house on
a lease option agreement let's say
five years when it gets to the end and i
don't want to buy the house what happens
to the tenants that are living there
thank you whatever you put in the
contract if you've got tenants there
and the contract says that if you want
to walk away from the property at the
end
you've got to hand it back as it was and
empty
then you're going to have to before you
before the end of the contract you're
gonna have to give the tenants notice to
leave
so it just depends on what you agreed
hope that helps
grigor i'm a first-time buyer and have
saved up for a deposit to buy a house
but now
i'm in two mines whether to buy and live
or buy to invest as i have no experience
my advice would always be to buy invest
i think buying to live
is a little bit of a waste of money
because
that's what we're told to do we're told
to save up buy a house to live in
and then pay off the mortgage and i'm
very against that system i think that it
will keep you poor it will keep you a
slave to money it will keep you in a rat
race job
you'd be much better off to put that
into an investment property that gives
you income
robert kiyosaki talks about this in the
book rich dad poor dad which is
the house that you live in is not an
asset because it's not putting money in
your back pocket every single month
i mean there are exceptions you could
buy a house to live in and then rent out
one or two of the rooms it could become
an asset so i'm not saying it's a
terrible
idea but my general guidance would
usually be
to buy to invest next afro promotions
i've got a question what stops someone
from signing an nda that's a
non-disclosure agreement
and still going behind your back to
proceed with the deal cutting you out
i'm assuming you can take legal action
but surely this will cost more than the
actual deal and you'll ultimately lose
no you will not lose if someone signs an
mda and then they break it and you take
it up legally with a small claims court
you will win
like every time because you've had an
mda now the question is whether you'd
want to
sometimes i tend to be a man of
principle and even if it's going to
take cost me 500 pounds you might think
is it worth the hassle
and the 500 pounds just to get a
thousand or two thousand pounds back
maybe it's not but if you've been if
someone has literally
signed an nda and then broken it that is
one of the worst
things that you can do as far as a court
is concerned so
most people won't do that because they
don't want to be sued and also they
most people care about their reputation
and if they do that it would make them
look like an absolute mug
so we've we are i've had hundreds of
nda's signs with my when i'm
when i was packaging and selling
hundreds of deals i was often using ndas
depending on the type of deal
and never once have i had anybody cut me
out so
what i have had is i've had some
investors pretend
that they already knew the property
existed but that's that's a whole other
story so i hope that helps
okay kian connor says hi samuel i'm
14 respect and i've been watching your
videos i want to have a house with as
little
money as possible don't we all
i want to know if i could buy a house
with a bridging loan and then refinance
the property
pay the loan back and have a free house
and then rent it and have passive income
hope that makes sense thank you and have
a good
day great stuff that's that's basically
effectively how it works correct so you
but it's more about the house itself
than the finance but
yeah if you take a bridging loan and you
buy a house and then you push the value
up
you can then refinance and use that
money to pay back the bridging loan
you're going to be left with that not
quite a free house it's going to be a
free house
and you didn't put any money down but
you are going to have a mortgage to pay
but you are correct you could rent that
out
it would pay the mortgage and also give
you an income so
congratulations and you're 14 go find
some good houses
and of course you're too young to get
bridging and things like that but hey i
bought my first house at 17 i put it in
my stepdad's name so
be creative keep hustling and respect
for being on the channel
supriya sharma says hi you are an
inspiration samuel i'm starting to put
your advice in action
question is having an interest only buy
to let mortgage a good idea
i want to turn my current home into a
buy to let
after taking some money for main home
deposit
i'm worried that monthly mortgage will
be too high for both properties any
advice police
uh supriya you can do that i'd buy to
let more listen
i'll buy to the mortgage is good or bad
it's just a loan it's just a mortgage
it depends it's more the more more to
the point is is your house a good house
if you've got a buy to let mortgage
typically you'll get 75 percent loan to
value
meaning if the house is worth 100 000
pounds the bank will give you
75 thousand pounds seventy five percent
of the value of the house
and then you're going to have a twenty
five thousand pounds
deposit left in the property and you're
gonna pay about three four percent on
the loan
so does it stack if you did that would
you be making profit and if you wouldn't
it might be worth
selling that house and buying one where
you would make money so
hope that helps mark's lifestyle
hi samuel i just graduated
congratulations
and want to get into the rent to rent
business i have about 25 000 pounds
saved up should i jump in
straight or wait and get a full-time job
i am concerned landlords may ask
how i'm going to pay the rent if i don't
have a full-time job now
so mark's lifestyle there is no right or
wrong answer
i usually advise if people are starting
property that they do it alongside a job
and that is just because i don't want my
students to be stressed up to their
eyeballs saying this has to work this
has to work this has to work because if
you're coming from a position of
desperation sometimes
it's not a good place and it even scares
people because if you're like you
desperately need a deal
you have desperate written on your
forehead people run away whereas if
you've got a job
it's giving you a nice income great as
long as your employer there's no
conflict of interest
and you've got you've got the time and
you can and you can start your
business or investing in property i
think it's smart to work alongside
however saying that there's also nothing
wrong with saying it depends how much
you need the money
if you've got responsibilities you've
got kids and mortgages and it's like oh
my gosh if i didn't get two grand
i'm done then then maybe get a job but
if it's a case of well actually you know
what
i'm i'm i'm single and i know i'm gonna
make this work
then great just go and start full time
as an entrepreneur in business there's
no right or wrong
i went straight full time but then when
i started
i was living with my mama so like i'm 17
living with my mom
so i could do that and as it happened it
worked out okay for me
but if if you're starting out and you're
29 and you've got
two cars and you're taking two holidays
you've got a wife and three kids
and you've got a mortgage to pay and if
you don't pay that mortgage you're gonna
get bad credit and then it probably
wouldn't be sensible to just quit your
job and suddenly just start ta-da
in property from scratch so it really
does
depend and only you can make up that
mind but make that decision but what i
will say is just do
something most people just don't do
anything they just think
one day one day one day one day one day
don't be that person
so take action and do it alongside a job
or do it
as your main job but do something afro
promotions i'm sure i've spoken to you
already on this
thing i have it's another question all
right let's see um
hi samuel also i know you probably can't
answer this question precisely but
roughly what percentage of value would
adding an
extra room to a house add to the final
value of the property
afro promotions it really just depends
it depends there's no i cannot give you
a percentage because it depends on
where it is it depends on if it's a
commercial property and you're going to
add an extra room
it might push the rental um price up
which is going to have a direct
correlation on the price and it's going
to be very mathematical
um best bet is to speak to an estate
agent and just say how much would this
property be worth i mean if you've got
if you if you're going to lose a room if
you've got a two bed house with two
reception rooms
and you now turn into a three bed but
you lose one of the reception rooms
but ta-da is now a three-bed because you
just put a bed in it you're not gonna
whack the value of the house up
if you do an extension you might there's
just so
many factors okay what else do we have
simon hill i've been renting my property
for six years now byron agency i'd love
to have the option to rent to rent
myself or do a lease option agreement
with the landlord but i'm not sure how
to go about it as i've never met them
would you recommend me knocking on their
door and introducing myself or asking
the agency to put me in contact with
them
if you know where they live give them a
letter and just say i love the house so
much i want to buy it can we have a chat
that's that and then if he gets in touch
you can just tell him i really love it
and i want to buy it the only problem is
i haven't got the money to put down
right now
so can i agree to buy off you fix down
the line and just
increase my rent a little bit and and
that can go towards it monthly or
whatever you want to do
the estate agent won't let won't put you
in touch with the agent with the
landlord
and the estate agent will probably just
be really rigid and it does not tick the
box that's what they're always like
usually
okay um alan i'm 13
i'm still confused and why some people
have debt and don't pay it off
how can you change debt to be good and
what makes
debt good or bad great question so
debt is debt the the reason what makes
it good or bad is what you use the debt
for
so if you take out you could go take out
a loan from sainsbury's for 10 grand
tomorrow
and your brother could go and take out
the exact same loan from the exact same
bank from sainsbury's
for you it could be good day and for him
it could be bad debt and the difference
would be that you
used that 10 grand and put it to work
and you buy something that's giving you
some nice interest there's paying back
sainsbury's interest
and more so you're using that to make
money
or you put that down into a business and
then that business starts making you
money
and and then with that money that you're
making you can pay back the loan but now
you've got an
asset that's good debt bad debt would be
if you use the ten thousand pounds and
you go and
go on holiday with it and then you get
back from the holiday and the sometimes
gone but now you just ten grand down
and the sickening thing is that in this
country
we are taught to get into good debt oh
sorry bad debt
we are taught to get into bad debt we
are brainwashed
that it's okay to get into bad debt and
then when i start teaching good debt i
get
jumped on and people say you know samuel
is encouraging that i'm like no no
no no you're encouraging debt and you're
encouraging bad debt i'm encouraging
good debt and there's very big
difference
bad debts really bad good debts really
good and all successful businesses
that i've ever known always run
off of good debt i don't know a business
that doesn't have good debt
but they don't teach this in school all
right next so well done for watching my
videos at 13 years old
alain marade i have a question about
rent-to-service accommodation when
running it
and you have a channel manager to manage
bookings etc would you still need a
property manager to check up on the
property or can you just ring the
cleaner and make sure it's in good
condition
also would you need to pay a maintenance
company every month or is that not
needed
so alan good question i use cleaners i
have i call them super cleaners or you
can call them
housekeepers and they cannot just be a
normal cleaner they need to
take ownership and my cleaners pretty
much run
the show uh maintenance you will need
you wanted a maintenance team or a
maintenance man ready
on demand to come out for emergencies
don't necessarily need to pay a monthly
fee though
so i hope that helps and every service
accommodation setup is always slightly
different
dj mugeni thanks for the brilliant job
of answering our questions
you are so welcome please do smash the
like button i hope that the thumb is
pointing up and i hope that it's blue
and not white
and educating us about property business
my name is david i've been a
i've been on your dfe congratulations
that's deal finding extravaganza it's
one of our amazing
training programs and i've got a flat
now in glasgow on
serviced accommodation well done that's
what happens when you get trained
i'm struggling to get another one at the
moment because we can't view properties
now physically
what are the things to look for to get
to make a decision on whether to buy the
property or leave it thanks again for
the good work
david you've been you've been trained
you know what you're doing you've bought
one it's service accommodation i assume
it's working well
i would not buy blind uh you've got to
view it and i don't know why you say you
can't view physically is that because
um i mean estate agents are opened up so
everything's open right now
so i would view it and just do what you
just did but do it again
but but but i don't know i don't know
i'd love to hear the figures of that you
got in glasgow
but this time if you bought it with your
own money use someone else's money show
them what you bought
and then and then get them in on a deal
but i hope you're doing well
keep me posted on how you get on drop me
a message maybe on insta or something
jevon marsh what are your five property
hacks
an example would be using rightmove and
sorting to upload dates so you can get
it first or checking the prices on mouse
price
keen to know any golden tips you have
jevon um i used to have lots of hacks
like that
checking the value right move and
scraping it
now i use an app i use an app called
deal saucer app now i
am a shareholder in the app so it's a
disclaimer but i'll put it in the link
in the description
um but basically what the app does is
you can
it it tells you the value of all the
houses because it scrapes information
from places like mouse price
you can check negative equity properties
it what calculates the return on
investment on every single property
that's on zoopla and the different sites
it's this incredible
app and it costs about 40 pounds um a
month and i think there's a
free subscription or very cheap i'm not
really sure but check in the description
i will leave a link if whoever's filming
this make sure that it's in the link
okay samia i have a home and three flats
which i rent
out the flats are cheap and central city
area so a
great rental yield would you recommend
selling the flats long term and buying
houses to reduce cost service charges
etc
and a faster growth in house prices it
depends on what what the
what the return on investment is you say
it's a great year what's the return you
say about service charges and stuff if
you're making a good return on those
little flats
i'd leave them sit on them because
if they're giving you a good cash flow
then that's all you need and it wouldn't
surprise me if they do go up in value
flats haven't gone up in va for
so long certainly in the midlands oh man
i've had some annoying properties that
just have
not gone up i've had a house down the
road and the flat and the flat stayed
still and the house has gone up and i
thought i wish i just bought more houses
however that might change so potentially
just sit on them
but it's all about return on investment
i'll be working on that not yield
sports compliations can you explain all
about deal sourcing like how much you
get paid for it criteria of a good deal
and what is an nda
so an nda is a non-disclosure agreement
you're going to use that when you find a
deal
and you want to show it to an investor
because you want him to pay you
but you don't want him to see the deal
and then go and just do it and cut you
out
so a deal source is someone that
packages deals and passes them on to
investors and charges a fee that is it
and and it's got to be a deal an
investor wants ie below market value
high cash flowing positive that's what
deal sourcing is i've sold hundreds of
deals and
it's very lucrative typically you're
gonna get paid between two to four
thousand pounds per deal that you sell
are mendola what is the farthest you
travel to find your golden patch
it's not so much about how far you'll
travel it's about making sure that your
patch
is close the properties are close by to
one another so i don't care if my patch
is seven hours away from where i live
because i'm not going to go there
but i do carry if my house is an hour
away and then another one's now that way
and another one's now that way
i want them close together and then i'm
gonna get a management
system set up where it's all nice
because otherwise if you've got
all over the place you're gonna have to
get different management systems in
different areas and that becomes a pain
michael says thank you for your generous
heart
you're welcome thank you i'm raising
some money to join samuel 365.
respect samuel 365 freedom that doesn't
know is where you get
one-on-one mentoring you get coaching
you get training and it's 95 pound a
month
and people say i'm expensive nope
compare that to university
my goodness but i'm wondering if i can
still go ahead and register limited
company now or wait until i am ready to
buy my first property
and also does the company name need to
have a word like
property in it or can i just pick any
name i like for my company
you can pick any name you like for your
company within reason
um i think there might be certain words
that you can't put in but it does not
have to have property in it i wouldn't
even set it up yet i just wait a bit
because
i mean you can set it up really easily
for about 15 pound and company's house
but if you
i mean with respect if you're saying
that you're saving up for samuel 365
which is 95 pound a month it might be
that you're
a little way before you're actually
going to buy buy a house for yourself
um maybe not maybe maybe i'm wrong but i
wouldn't rush
to get business cards and set a company
up and get a logo and
all that i'd be rushing to make some
money
so i hope that helps christopher hubbard
i'm in a town where there's no
university or college is it possible to
get a house and turn it into a hmo or
would it be a waste of time
speak to a hmn management company in the
area you'd be surprised
jay kelwick when selling deals do you
not have to pay do you have to pay tax
on the amount you charge the investors
yes sadly you do you have to pay tax on
pretty much any money that you make
however what you want to do to avoid
paying tax
is you want to buy stuff that's
tax-deductible
you're probably buying stuff at the
moment that you could claim back as
tax-deductible you don't even know it
um you know you go out for a dinner and
you talk business with your friend or
you're chatting about business if you're
like me you're talking about business
all the time that dinner is
tax-deductible
you join samuel 365. you pay 95 pound a
month that is tax deductible because
it's
trainees towards your business so you
want to just make sure that
you're you're claiming everything as an
expense
which is being knocked off your profit
meaning that you're going to pay
less tax but yeah you are going to have
to pay tax if you're selling deals
making money
renting out houses you're gonna have to
pay tax
okay um crypto let's go
says love your energy man you're so
welcome i love your
your name these videos are great as i do
worry about the future of my job with
covid19 my dad has two to three
properties that he hides from the tax
man could he just sell them to a limited
company he owns
and be safe and legit that way as he has
owned these properties for many years
um well as i just said in my last uh my
last answer you're gonna have to pay tax
you know you can't
get around not paying tax they will come
for you the worst person to steal from
in the world
is the is the government if you steal
from the government they're going to
come for you like a ton of bricks
they're going to strip you
dry they're going to take your blood
they're going to eat your kids
so if i was in you your dad's situation
for sure you can move it over to a
limited company if you say a limited
company you're gonna really struggle to
hide it because
it's public you're gonna have to get
someone to do your accounts once a year
um in terms of the other properties if
he's managed to
lie low another thing is if you're not
paying tax and you kind of you're gonna
have to lie low
i don't i don't like lying low i get
reported to the tax people because
sometimes people think i don't pay taxes
or they just try and waste my time to
upset me but they've been and they've
investigated me and you know what
happened they actually owed me money
because i
accidentally overpaid i think it was
only a very small amount but that was
kind of cool
because i don't want to be laying low
you know i've got a couple properties
and i'm renting them out but
no one knows about it i'm gonna lay i
don't want to be laying low i want to be
telling the world of my property
investor and building my portfolio and
paying my taxes
so pay your taxes but do be smart do be
smart make sure that you're claiming tax
deductible stuff and
for sure but focus mostly on making
money not saving money
and um should you go back and pay
everything that you
owe that slipped into the net probably
yes probably yes but
i don't judge you if you don't do that
at all
but i would never never never advise um
avoiding taxes illegally you know you
want to get around and find loopholes
go crazy do it and you know what a lot
of poor people will have a go at rich
people just for finding loopholes
no that's fine i find loopholes i will
not pay tax legally absolutely and
people will get all annoyed you know
oh but that that's just called being
smart
but not paying tax illegally that's been
stupid
armando another bonus from renting where
you live is if you split up with your
wife and she becomes
nasty she can't take your house away
from you because it's not yours
yeah yeah okay i don't know if that's a
question or
that's not what i rent by the way but um
yeah
fair sure okay bmx vloggers
have you ever lived in litchfield yes i
have lived in litchfield
i lived there previously to beckonsfield
is where i live now
dave jones how would you use 70 000
pounds to start a journey to become
financially free brr multiple buy to let
some cheaper end mixture of both brr
take the 70 grand put it in pull it out
put it in pull it out as many times as
you can buy it refurbish it we finance
it
rent it aja akan what strategy would you
use to be a property cash
millionaire i became a millionaire
through deal packaging
i became financially free by buying
houses with other people's money and
lease options and hmos
that i became financially free became a
millionaire from them packaging and
selling deals to other people
so um that's just my experience
is zeldin also no offense what has been
the worst
point biggest failure of your life oh
jeez this is deep
um when doing real estate okay if you
don't want to answer that's fine
thank you thank you for my get out of
jail card what's been the hardest thing
oh man i don't even know right now i
think probably
when you become successful you sometimes
can
alienate people that were your homies
your friends
family school friends you don't feel any
different you feel just the same
like hey what's up people start tweeting
you know whispering and being a bit
weird
um i think for me that was probably the
hardest thing it was just it was just
the um more on the on a relational side
and you suddenly start getting lots of
people that want to be your friend but
maybe for the wrong reasons you don't
know who you can trust
and then some of the older people that
you used to be really good good friends
with
you can't quite relate in the same way
you know starting on holiday and they
might want to go to wales and
in a caravan uh that's like well i was
very that was very normal for me i want
to go to dubai and stay at the most
fancy
hotel so it's just it's just different
so yeah that's probably the hardest
thing
but i'm probably gonna start doing more
videos on youtube around
hardships not not so much around like my
personal life but just
things that have gone property deals
that have gone wrong and stuff like that
the flip side i mean i get excused so
often of just making everything rosy and
the truth is
because to be honest as far as business
and my property investments have been
mostly they've kind of been pretty rosy
i've been very successful i'm 29 years
old i've done
quite well people say what's your
biggest regret or biggest mistakes it's
like well to be honest
i've done all right so for me to start
saying oh man i've got so many regrets
would just be me being
unreal and not true um but however that
i have lost money on deals so i'm gonna
be talking about those as well hope that
helps
okay i'll just do maybe one uh or or two
more
okay same guy says specifically where
did you learn about all the terms
in real estate or did you just learn
from the internet i just learned by but
by
the terms just by doing it and being
trained i went on a lot of training
programs
a lot of courses and stuff i also
paid for business mentors and then i
did it alongside you know if you just go
on lots of training courses but don't do
it you'll be a course junkie
but then if you just do it without the
training then you you're going to be
a motivated idiot that just get you're
going to have a bash and you're going to
have a crash
you need to do the two together in my
opinion last question
i share i have 80 000 pounds to invest
in property
i'm 70 years old and no chance of a
mortgage what suggestions can you give
me
i would suggest that you team up with
somebody and
it's just you know what you're in the
same situation as me but you're in a
better position because you're older
you're wiser and you've got 70 grand
when i started out i was 17 years old
and i didn't have
the money that you have and i also
couldn't get the mortgage
and i put it in a family member's name
and managed to do a no money down deal
but if you've got the money
i just find like a grandson or a son or
daughter
or a friend that you can team up with
let them do the hard work and the
you know the all the running around and
stuff
and you put the money in and give them a
tiny percentage
if you said to some people who maybe are
in their 30s and they're really keen to
get into property if you said look i've
got 70 grand
i'll put it into the deals i'll find the
properties but i want you to manage it
and do everything and i'll just give you
five percent
stake in the property but it's you're
going to be the mortgage host so to
speak
a little joint venture the people who
snap your arm off of that so it's always
about when you've got a gap whether
you're 17 or whether you're 70
whether you've got money or whether
you've not got money like wherever
you're at
you just got to think what's my gap and
how can i partner with someone
to fill that gap but at the same time
how can i grow
and get better so that my gaps fail but
you're always gonna have gaps you're
always gonna need
um people no one's self-made you're
always gonna need people
to step in and help you in your gap so
folks thank you so much you know i
really enjoy doing these q a sundays
it's like
one of them one of my favorite days is
now sundays i love reading your
questions so comment your questions
again smash the like button i want to
see you the blue thumb
up the blue thumb not white and
subscribe turn the notification bell on
because honestly if you're asking
questions below
there's a very good chance i'll be
answering your question next week so you
need to not only subscribe
but press that little notification bell
so that when the video comes up
you get pings and you can watch it and
you can have your questions answered
around property thanks so much peace out
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you